les géants d'internet leurs réseaux
sociaux menace-t-il notre démocratie
sont ils devenus trop puissant pour
répondre à ces questions je reçois
robert et les kerr bonsoir soit
bienvenue vous êtes philosophe écrivain
c'est votre livre réseaux sociaux la
guerre des léviathan qui vous a donné
envie d'organiser ce débat il est publié
ce livre aux éditions du rocher à smala
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
maîtresse de conférences à sciences po
vous enseigner les enjeux éthiques
énumérer politique de l'économie
numérique merci et bienvenu merci d'être
là jean bernard schmid vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes co fondateur
directeur général de spahis si vous êtes
prof à sciences po également des espaces
y passiez du coup si plate forme vidéo
qui aiguise l'esprit critique du citoyen
notamment pour contrer la désinformation
voilà un enjeu majeur j'accueille avait
également avec nous il est temps en
visioconférence jambes acier qui est
streamer politique sur twitch bon soit
jean mathia voulzy vulgariser
l'actualité politique notamment avec un
débat hebdomadaire a tutti les bacs site
ça veut dire quoi streamer politique
tient je vous pose une petite question
est très rapide ça veut dire que je
commente l'actualité politique
destination des internautes pour leur
permettre de la suivre voilà et c'est
diffusé en streaming
absolument c'est sa ville ses nerfs en
partie aussi c'est ça la logique et
matthieu croissandeau qui est toujours à
mes côtés robert redeker je commence
avec vous puisque vous êtes à l'origine
avec votre livre de 2,2 ce débat
évidemment
vous dites que les réseaux sociaux
propriété des géants on va pas tous les
citer mais google amazon facebook apple
microsoft et on a aussi en chine on peut
rajouter twitter etc sont entrés en
guerre contre les états ya plusieurs
idées fortes dans votre livre cette
notion de pouvoir de guerre pour le
pouvoir la fin de la sacralisation de la
de la vie privée la fin de l'opinion
publique aussi souk de nos démocraties
vous dites que c'est une révolution
qu'on a n'a pas encore bien pris
conscience c'est ça la révolution
numérique a des aspects très nombreux
que l'on découvre peu à peu au fur et à
mesure que les années passent et que des
événements se déroulent la crise du
récente dans laquelle nous sommes encore
dues qu'ovide à accélérer certaines
tendances notamment par rapport à la vie
privée
rapport sans doute à la disparition de
cette invention
formidable de la bourgeoisie
je suis désolé défendant la bourgeoisie
ça ne se fait pas enfin si karl marx
vous-même de vie pierre leroux mais la
bourgeoisie a quand même inventé deux
choses à partir de la notion d'opinion
publique qui est apparu au xviiie siècle
c'est quand qu'ils fixent vraiment ce
que l'opinion publique d'hier à partir
du développement de ce qu'il appelle un
public qui lie nous avons vu l'invention
de la vie privée et du domicile privé
c'est-à-dire de deux espaces un espace
intérieur et la prolongation de cet
espace intérieur des espaces physiques
où habitait inviolable or on a vu une
accélération de de la disparition de ces
deux espaces
par la puissance des technologies
numériques aussi part à la puissance des
gars femmes à l'occasion de la crise du
coc jean ça s'est renforcée on va
revenir évidemment sur les autres
éléments de réflexion mais d'autres lots
iront troppo logique metoffice bien sûr
on va aller développer mais sur cette
question de la vie privée asma mais la
maladresse et les étapes ce que là on
est dans la question des léviathan des
nouveau léviathan qui concurrencent les
états traditionnels les états sont quand
même en train de légiférer il ya un
certain nombre de lois qui sont déjà
passés il ya la loi car gpd donc qui
réglemente la protection des données il
ya ce qu'on a tous vécu sur nos deux
ordinateurs c'est à dire c'est le fait
que les cons on peut maintenant plus
facilement refuser les cookies ou les
villes fait oui moi je le fais bravo
mais
maintenant c'est un peu plus facile
quand même ça apparaît un peu mieux sur
les écrans est d'ailleurs moi ça me
permet de juger aussi le site sur lequel
je suis fan qui voulait qu'il faut il
faut lire le
descriptif datant du gs crypte if bon
mais ça va je mets tout accepter j'ai
tort oui mais alors ça ça a changé
justement donc c'est vrai que c'est plus
facile de refuser ces cookies qui
alimente en donnait effectivement les
géants d'internet donc les les états
rayspan r travailler plus sur séché sur
la vie privée hors jeu ils sont et
seront délivrés et des états et c'est
très intéressant que vous preniez à la
question de langue justement étatiques
et non pas de langue des méchants gaza
où des méchantes meta plateforme
américaine alors le temps politique
n'est pas le temps technologique ça
c'est clair et il ya un certain nombre
de législations qui ont eu lieu alors
gpd ou qui sont en cours du jt a servi
sa quête qui a été présenté en fin
d'année dernière aux états unis à
beaucoup de réflexion de débat sur la
fameuse section de 130 du statut des
réseaux sociaux donc en effet les états
ne reste pas inerte et des discussions
sont en cours et les lignes sont en
train de bouger par rapport à ça
maintenant il ya un point qui est très
juste c'est la question de la mise en
oeuvre c'est à dire qu'il ne suffit pas
de créer une loi ou d'avoir une espèce d
inflation législative typiquement on en
parlera peut-être mais sur la question
de la modération en tout cas de la delà
de la régulation des contenus illicites
la loi existe mais j'ai 180 donc la
vraie le vrai un des vrais sujets c'est
la question de la mise en oeuvre de lois
existantes qui sont en train d'être
d'être d'être adopté d'une part et puis
d'autre part c'est le rôle très ambigu
on en parlera peut-être aussi de ces
états là c'est à dire que souvent on
voit un continuum et les réseaux sociaux
sont aussi un terrain de jeu pour les
états dans des guerres informationnel
dans la 10 dans la diffusion de fake use
ou de news qui sont notre g et qui sont
pas forcément fake d'ailleurs on l'a vu
sur cambridge analytica ce n'était pas
forcément de la fée qui nous mais c'est
de la manipulation d'informations
réelles et puis sur surtout les
histoires de surveillance c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a aussi une inflation
de lois sécuritaires et qui capte
beaucoup de data de données personnelles
grâce aux traces numériques qu'on
l'assumé mais cette réflexion
sur notre vie privée sur la fin de la
vie privée d'une certaine façon qu'on
accepte les uns les autres en en
cliquant sur ok effectivement quand on
quand on prend une nouvelle appli ça
c'est quand même vous le reconnaissez un
danger c'est celle objets ou ça doit
être en tout cas l'objet d'une vraie
discussion collective en réalité c'est
la question qui sous jacente au delà de
la question de la vie privée c'est la
question du choix de société qu'on va
construire avec ces nouvelles
technologies et là est la vraie question
sous jacente c'est la question du libre
arbitre et de l'autodétermination en
réalité robert redeker on la zone libre
arbitre
je crois qu'on le fasse aux réseaux
sociaux de moins en moins c'est de plus
en plus difficile de de la voir faire le
livre arbitres c'est le résultat d'une
certaine évolution culturelle et
politique à l'intérieur d'un certain
type de société est évident que nous
sommes dans une phase de transition et
que l'on ne sait pas trop quel type de
société avec une puissance du numérique
nous allons avoir alors je voulais
simplement rebondir sur ce que vient de
dire notre
île il ya encore plus lorsque vous êtes
à votre domicile se développe désormais
la domotique c'est à dire un certain
nombre de facultés vous avez physique
mais aussi de plus en plus des facultés
intellectuelles vous en débarrasser et
les appareils vont le faire à votre
place dont vous dépouiller donc quand
même de quelque chose qui est essentiel
à à l'humanité je crois que vous
régressez un peu nous infantiliser voilà
vous avez l'idée d'une chance son cousin
de réécouter et hop alexa intervient
elle arrive sur l'autre bande son
croyait être vous mettez des caméras
pour surveiller
vos animaux vos enfants quand vous êtes
loin mais finalement les caméras vous
surveille aussi parce que c'est pas
anodin qui est des caméras de
surveillance à l'intérieur de votre
domicile
cela c'est quelque chose à penser et qui
est tout à fait nouveau à ceux de red
hat jean bernard schmidt vous vous
analysez effectivement ces questions
dans d'autres médias c'est pas ici est
ce que vous diriez sur cette question
serait sur la vie privée ensuite on
abordant les hôtes m vous vous diriez
qu'il ya quand même une prise de
conscience qui se fait petit à petit
cerf qui a eu une première année de la
révolution numérique ou sans rendez pas
compte ensuite on a commencé à dire
attention quand c'est gratuit c'est vous
le produit donc ça c'est une phrase
qu'on a beaucoup entendu et qui est
vraiment importante à intégrer dans
notre dans nos usages de des outils
numériques est ce que vous direz que la
prise de conscience commence quand elle
commence nécessairement parce que déjà
il ya sept premiers ce premier choix
qu'on vous demande systématiquement en
arrivant sur un site internet en vous
demandant de valider ou non les colis
donc vous avez une prise de conscience
la réalité c'est que souvent on va très
vite on a besoin de quelque chose on
valide lorsqu'on a le temps de réfléchir
oui on va regarder autant voire plus si
tenté que ça soit clair on va regarder
mais la majeure partie du temps je vous
rejoins on valide très vite parce que en
général on a une vision assez
utilitariste de son accès internet donc
on veut aller vite mais au-delà de ça
moi je trouve je trouves pas qu'elle
progresse pas tant que ça et je pense
quand même que nous nous renonçons à une
énorme partie de notre intimité dans l'
usage des réseaux sociaux et
oui précisément sur certaines choses
enfin je trouve que l'on n'a pas encore
pris conscience par exemple du nombre
d'informations confidentielles que l'on
livre à facebook à google amazon sans
s'en apercevoir
mais nous livrons des pans entiers de
notre intimité amazon c'est le premier
magasin du monde il sait tout tout tout
de nous et d'ailleurs vous parliez d'une
au jam il va même vous proposer ce que
vous n'avez pas envie d'acheter et dans
90% des cas c'est ce que vous allez
faire on le sait donc moi je trouve que
non je trouve que c'est pas si simple
gia il ya effectivement et là je vous
rejoins il ya quand même il faut s'en
féliciter
une dimension politique européenne
surtout européenne d'ailleurs parce que
il ya quand même une prise de conscience
a quand même alors gpd c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a ses pales c'est loin
d'être parfait mais ça a marqué les
esprits mais si on est mieux protégé en
europe qayyum sur la ville avait
d'ailleurs coûté beaucoup de sites
américains beaucoup de bons se sont
quand même mis à accepter les règles de
l'air gpd parce que c'est finalement
l'europe à dos mais c'est le règlement
général à votre action
avec aussi même si c'est symbolique a eu
des amants d'un souvenez-vous
sur fond de l'air gpd notamment dictée
par la annoncé par la cnil envers google
par exemple pour non utilisation de dés
ou mauvaise utilisation pardon des
données personnelles même si c'est
symbolique ça existe quand même moi je
trouve que dans les comportements
individuels ça encore énormément de mal
à avancer il ya une petite prise de
conscience il y a 20 ans on était
beaucoup de personnes s'étant
d'idéologie de la numérisation heureuse
comme il y avait vraiment égalisation
heureuse donc il y avait une sorte
d'utopie de liberté une sorte d'utopie
libertaire d'internet et cela
aujourd'hui c'est quand même
complètement passé deux saisons et plus
personne ne manche dans
sept jours doit on va revenir sur la
lame ne les menace pour la démocratie je
vais me tourner vers jean m'assieds donc
jean mathia tweet c'est un réseau social
qui s'adresse aux jeunes
double question c'est quoi la moyenne
d'âge de votre public et peut-être aussi
c'est plus important pourquoi vouloir
parler politique
cela moyenne d'âge de mon public c'est
24 ans donc à peu près entre 25 et 30
ans de moins que celui de la télévision
et je lui parle de politique parce que
parce que parce que la politique
appartient à tout le monde en démocratie
elle est censée appartenir à tout le
monde or il se trouve que les jeunes
témoignent d'un manque cruel d'accès à
la politique parce qu'ils ne consomment
plus les médias traditionnels qu'ils ont
donc besoin de se reporter sur des
plates formes qu'ils fréquentent
quotidiennement et puis par ailleurs les
jeunes ont démontré quand même au cours
de l'histoire et même jusqu'à très
récemment leur implication dans les
mouvements politiques dans les
phénomènes politiques on parle du climat
on parle du mouvement mis tout on parle
des gilets jaunes on parle de tout un
tas de mouvement dans lesquels
d'ailleurs internet n'a pas eu un rôle
neutre donc donc voilà donc les jeunes
vivent avec internet au quotidien vivent
avec les réseaux sociaux au quotidien et
donc il ya aucune raison qu'on aille pas
discuter avec eux de politique sur ces
réseaux et est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment finalement que
vos émissions apporte humblement leur
pierre à au fonctionnement de notre
démocratie aujourd'hui parce qu'on peut
aussi inverser la logique veut dire que
les réseaux sociaux peuvent être des
outils de démocratie mais parce que
exactement en fait en fait mes émissions
oui j'estime humblement qu'elle est
qu'elles apportent leur pierre à
l'édifice parce que c'est mon angle
éditorial à moi parce que c'est la
décision que j'ai prise d'en faire ça
mais on pourra très justement me
rétorquer que sur les réseaux sociaux on
peut aussi faire des choses absolument
horrible et très antidémocratique et
c'est parfaitement vrai il s'agit pas je
ne suis pas du tout un techno bea qui va
vous expliquer que la démocratie c'est
grâce à internet que ça existe on a vu
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis avec
trump on voit ce qui se passe aussi en
france avec zemmour oui internet peut
aussi servir à des choses très négative
néanmoins encore une fois internet peut
être un outil très puissant de
d'implication citoyenne de démocratie
participative c'est pas pour rien qu
énormément d'élus locaux s'y mettent à
utiliser les réseaux sociaux pour
dialoguer avec avec leurs administrés
avec leurs électeurs ce n'est pas pour
rien que le sénat lui-même s'y est mis
en créant une plate forme de pétition en
ligne donc voila vous voyez que c'est
vraiment à double tranchant internet
c'est un outil qu'on peut utiliser dans
tous les sens
asma la sks que leur jeu repose la
question générale du débat est-ce que
vous pensez que les réseaux sociaux et
finalement c'est géant d'internet qui
sont derrière on verra la liste de ceux
qui possède quoi sont une menace pour
nos démocraties aujourd'hui question
elle est vaste et très vaste et elle ne
peut pas se contenter d'une réponse
binaire donc oui et non en réalité enfin
ce qu'on entend ce que disait jean macé
très justement est ce qu'on entend en
filigrane c'est que les réseaux sociaux
sont à la fois une espèce de pharmakon
c'est à la fois un remède on l'a vu pour
les révolutions arabes ça a permis aussi
une forme d'emploi aux mains d'un
certain nombre d'actions collectives
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
a priori les gilet jaune on peut au
départ s'organiser autour de ça et c'est
oui ou non cette idée pardon prime
parenthèse d'une société qui était très
pyramidale et si je viens un peu plus
horizontale alors ça ça change
larchitecture démocratique elle-même et
la distribution de la parole hélas ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que tout
d'un coup les états aussi pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sur réguler loi le projet
de loi via par exemple c'est qu'ils ne
restent heureusement que qu'à l'état de
projet mais c'est la question aussi du
monopole de l'état qui a abandonné avait
le contrôle de l'ensemble des cas des
canaux d'information et puis qui tout
d'un coup sans voient dépossédés met
donc là il ya un vrai sujet / / / le
rôle de l'état mais pour revenir la
question est ce que les réseaux sociaux
sont une menace pour la démocratie
oui et non pour une raison très simple
c'est que tout dépend ce qu'on en fait
et il nous faudra surtout pas dans le
raisonnement confondre cause des
symptômes les réseaux sociaux amplifie
un phénomène le monétise souvent
polarise ou participent à une
polarisation mais attention ce qui est
permis sur les réseaux sociaux en
réalité c'est bien une articulation de
la société elle même donc on va y
retrouve exactement les mêmes abus le
sexisme discriminations le racisme la
xénophobie les contenus complètement
illicites etc oui mais avec avec avec
peut-être moins de contrôle possible
parce qu'il ya l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que y'a peut-être
les réseaux sont tous en tout cas on va
dire que les géants d'internet se donne
pas suffisamment les moyens de modérer
les débordements la question c'est quel
est le rôle et la responsabilité des
plateformes et en effet ça c'est un vrai
sujet d'où les régulations et les
projets de régulation qui sont
actuellement en cours c'est pour ça que
je parlais au début de temporalité d'un
temps politique qui suit le temps
technologique une accélération
phénoménale mais ça veut pas dire que
tout est foutu et ça ne veut pas dire
que l'image qu'on a un instant t et
celle qui va être ou qu'on va subir dans
10 20 ans mathieu à quel point ça
bouleverse le fonctionnement politique
pour vous là où ça le bouleverse elle
peut moi ce qui me frappe le plus c'est
que c'est un impensé politique il ya une
tentative de régulation vous l'avais dit
il ya une tentative de protection des
données avec un air dépité mais on est
quand même face à un phénomène qui vous
verse gens vers l'adie l'intimité qui
percute l'enfance de plein fouet jusqu'à
l'âge adulte la sexualité qui percute
l'économie par cette économie de vous le
disais tout à l'heure on se déleste de
tout l'état ferrer bien que la vie et
les enfants nés en 2010 exactement et
aux gros on est face à des phénomènes
énormes qui sont pas le pro de fa qui se
trouve sur réseaux sociaux mais ce n'est
pas tout les réseaux sociaux sur l'image
la société et aucun homme politique
aujourd'hui ne parle de sa personne vous
pouvez prendre tout le spectre politique
tout le monde s'en fiche tout le monde
se dit qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
mon gamin garçon porte à toute la
journée qu'on est dans la culture du
like l'individualisme du clain et
personne ne parle de ça après ce que ça
a changé dans la vie politique et c'est
là où je rejoins c'est que c'est un
facteur de diffusion et de mobilisation
extraordinaire des réseaux sociaux le
problème c'est que il est à la merci de
gens qui peuvent l'utiliser à des fins
malveillantes et on l'a bien vu et que
surtout là où ça change beaucoup à mes
yeux c'est qu'on passe d'une culture de
l'offre à une culture de la demande ce
qu'ils ne venaient enrichi pas forcément
dans la tête des gens je vous dis d'un
point de vue des médias par exemple
avant dans un journal on disait alors
vous est sans nulle aux fins de ça parce
que ça nous paraît important même si
c'est pas forcément le premier réflexe
du lecteur et puis voilà il ya une
démarche éditoriale aujourd'hui c'est
l'inversé de lettres demande donc je je
suis fan du psg des questions
environnementales et le phénomène btu et
je peux avoir sur mon fils oui on
s'enferme et a
fini par sur des gens qui pensent que
moi donc tous nos gros même ce phénomène
là de clusters idéologique qui sont
créées par les réseaux sociaux est
alimenté par les eaux sociaux à cause
des algorithmes ça n'ait pas pensé ça
n'évolue pas oui 6 à 8
ce mode y ait ce hashtag sur les les
enfants nés en 2010 mais pardon mais ça
s'est passé à chaque entrée en sixième
quand c'est au nom dans l'est ont montré
toujours du doigt les petits sixièmes et
les années précédentes il avait acheté
que 2009 hashtag d'action bien sûr que
ce soit beaucoup plus grave cette année
je crois que c'est une une violence
psychologique tout à fait différente de
ce que je suis d'accord sur le
harcèlement à l'école je vous estimez le
fait que les réseaux sociaux soit un
outil
nous avons connu en effet nous avons
connu tous de la violence à l'école de
la violence physique alors je vais
rapidement
mon père et ma mère sont tellement je
suis allemand né en france en 1954 neuf
ans après la fin de la guerre est
évidemment j'étais à l'école traité de
sale
bon et puis il y avait des bagarres de
la violence physique ça veut former mais
le harcèlement numérique c'est autre
chose c'est beaucoup plus destructeur
que les bagarres physiques entre garçons
que nous avons tous connu et puis si je
peux me permettre à 17 h à l'école mais
ça s'arrêtait à la maison ça aujourd'hui
ça ne continuerait à la maison toute la
nuit
tout à fait différent
s'inquiéter de cela voilà je suis
d'accord avec vous j'ai dit je disais
juste que le hashtag 2010 il y en a eu
les années précédentes et c'est juste
parce que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale est montée au créneau que
c'est devenu un sujet de d'actualité
bref jean bernard schmidt sur cette
question du pouvoir d des géants
d'internet et peut-être de leur de leur
volonté à scier une idéologie derrière
d'après vous est ce qu'à une volonté
politique de la part de ces de ses
patrons alors ça c'est un débat c'est
très intéressant parce que alors on
déborde un peu mais c'est vrai que si on
s'interroge vraiment sur le profil des
géants des fondateurs déjà en internet
mais là on se rend compte que souvent ce
sont des on a confié une évolution
profonde de nos démocraties à des gens
qui alors un ne sont pas élus hier n'ont
pas eu à un moment ou un autre à
répondre de responsabilité a proposé un
programme etc et puis ce sont des
profils souvent ce sont des des techno
sont des gens alors on oublie souvent ce
sont des gens issus de la technologie
bon pourquoi pas mais il faut réguler sa
avait essayé de contrebalancer leur
pouvoir leur intention c'est pas pour
rien par exemple qu'aujourd'hui on dit
beaucoup que ils sont obsédés par tous
ce qu'est transhumanisme etc c'est un
peu leur obsession là dessus donc leur
idéologie il ya plein de possibilités et
plein de 10 dès qu'on peut avoir dessus
mais ce sont souvent des gens amoureux
de la technologie qui pensent ça c'est
très important que la technologie peut
répondre à quasiment tous nos problèmes
et surtout améliorer l'être humain à
tous les niveaux et tout ça et le
problème c'est que ces unis et moi là où
je rejoins alors entièrement ce que dit
mathieu sur l'absence de prise de
conscience des politiques à travers le
monde hein je pense et et sur le fait
que ça quand même un impact énorme sur
nos démocraties c'est que justement vous
me demandiez bon ben voilà qu'est ce
qu'ils ont derrière la tête mais ça ça
doit être contrebalancé or aujourd'hui
moi je trouve que ça n'est pas
suffisamment contrebalancer est certes
je suis d'accord sur le fait que notre
démocratie nos démocraties on
ddd biais des défauts etc les réseaux
sociaux ça je trouve c'est fondamental
amplifie en fait tous et tous et tout
cet or je trouve que nous aurions besoin
collectivement au contraire de
garde-fous de régulation et ça ils
amplifient et résultat ils ont tendance
à fragmenter la société et c'est ça qui
met en danger à mes yeux le plus ce
qu'est le débat collectif qui doit être
au contraire ce que l'on doit au maximum
mettre de côté et sécurisé alors est ce
que est ce que les états et notamment
l'état français essaient de réagir on va
écouter ce que disait le présent l'un
public 16 juin dernier on est au salon
viva tech il pointe du doigt la
puissance des géants du numérique
écouter on a des conglomérats qui à un
moment donné sont mauvais pour le pays
parce que comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
très bien dit pour le secteur il est une
innovation parce qu'ils ont trop
d'intérêts
ils empêchent les nouveaux et novateurs
devenu la solution c'est le
démantèlement by cc dans le débat
américain vous l'avez vu lors de la
campagne et donc c'est évident qu'à un
moment dé cette question continuera de
se poser je pense qu'elle est légitime à
ce moment-là qu'elle commence régisseur
d'entendre emmanuel macron sur ce sur ce
thème là je rappelle que vous enseignez
les enjeux éthiques et politiques de
l'économie numérique donc on est
vraiment au coeur de votre
mon sujet alors pour rebondir sur ce qui
est sûr ce qui a été dit c'est très
juste mais pour pour aller un peu plus
loin dans l'action la régulation il faut
d'abord décortiquer les modèles
économiques qui sont derrière j'en étais
de la polarisation qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux et les effets de masse
on est en effet le cyber harcèlement est
beaucoup plus important parce que c'est
en continu et que la volumétrie beaucoup
plus incontournable mais c'est la
question des modèles économiques est en
réalité c'est très bête mais au delà des
questions des débats sur l'idéologie ou
quoi c'est en fait des plateformes qui
sont là pour capter l'attention
l'économie de l'attention de façon à
vous exposer un maximum à la publicité
oui en avant du business avant d'avoir
les entreprises instance ou une
idéologie il ya du business et du
business c'était pourtant jamais c'est
d'abord ça saignait maximisation du
profit il se trouve que ce qu'il m'a
fait qu est ce qui maximise ses deux
l'insensible de l'intangible c'est notre
attention ces novices notre vie privée
c'est nos données personnelles etc qui
crée la valeur économique alors sur la
question du démantèlement posé la
question à emmanuel macron pourquoi pas
ce sont des entreprises américaines sous
juridiction américaine mais aussi des
entreprises chinoises qui sont
puissantes info souvent souvent les
oubliées mais bon oui mais c'est pas les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui donc on
utilise sont essentiellement américains
dieu à tik tok à particules à la tic toc
et quelques dans son journal chinois
c'est facebook un certain style ça a été
repris par un serveur web jourdain à
perdre mais on va faire la liste un peu
à qui appartiennent les réseaux sociaux
je me suis posé la question tout à
l'heure alors évidemment elle est pas
totalement exhaustive mais bon c'était
c'est intéressant microsoft via linkedin
facebook y en a beaucoup et sap
instagram
twitter si twitter amazon possède switch
on en parlait tout à l'heure google
c'est youtube est effectivement tik tok
et et
chinois ou chinoises
démantèlement démantèlement est ce que
c'est tout simplement possible est ce
que ça vous semble ou alors il faudrait
une gouvernance mondiale qui prennent
cette décision et là je pense que je
suis dans l'utopie
pas si utopique utopique que ça parce
qu'il ya de vraies de vraies discussions
aujourd'hui dans mon doigt a rejoint
essentiellement aux états unis parce que
ça c'est marrant mais beaucoup de la
recherche se fait là-bas aussi sur les
questions de régulation alors il se
trouve que biden a mis en place toute
une nouvelle administration avec l'ina
cannes etc qui sont vraiment sur des
positions anti trust ou en tout cas de
régulation qui sont assez radical par
rapport à ce qu'on pouvait connaître des
états unis jusque là qui était un peu
sur du laisser faire
sur la question du démantèlement est ce
que c'est faisable d'un point de vue du
droit et juridique oui tant que la doxa
antitrust évolué elle en train d'évoluer
en ce sens aux états unis après la
question c'est la vraie question c'est
est ce que démentent les sera efficace
et là je suis beaucoup plus dubitatif
pour une raison très simple c'est que
sait on si on sait en cassant deux de
puissance que de toute façon on n'arrive
pas à comprendre qui de toute façon par
leurs modèles économiques sont par
nature monopolistique de toute façon je
ne vois pas en quoi on règle
fondamentalement le problème
du démantèlement la question de la
responsabilisation bien sûr des plateaux
et c'est tout le débat
du jury ce qu'on leur donne un statut
correspondant à au statut d'éditeur en
compte dans le droit français de la
presse ou est hébergeur et s voilà
d'ailleurs depuis le début on dit
réseaux sociaux parce que c'est le terme
français qu'on utilise depuis des années
mais on devrait dire médias sociaux
comme les britanniques se sont des
médias avant tout je voulais rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit même allez
un petit peu plus loin il y as chez
google une véritable utopie
anthropologique et politiquement c'est
changer l'homme sert le transhumanisme
mais c'est changer une transformer
complètement la politique ça iran vous
dit que ça va au delà du business et
olivia temps anciens qui est arrivé
enfin qui fondent l'europe à partir du
xviie siècle thomas hobbes c'est l'état
souverain tels que nous connaissons
substituer de nouvelles souveraineté à
partir d'une transformation de l'homme
alors souvenons nous thomas obs au 18 du
lit vite du léviathan que dit-il le mou
de base du lait via trans et faisant
l'homme car c'est ça l'état fait l'homme
construit l'homme et je crois que l'a
fait je crois que j'ai lu les textes je
sais que il y à une utopie politique
derrière cela l'utopie politique qui est
née au début de la cybernétique avec
norbert guiner après la seconde guerre
mondiale
wiener et les premiers cybernéticiens
était très déçu par l'homme et par la
politique qui a abouti à cette
catastrophe que fut la seconde guerre
mondiale et c'est sur le fond de cette
déception qu'ils ont commencé à imaginer
finalement que les machines ferait tout
à nos places un autre placement
des algorithmes passeront une autre
place des âneries c'est donc une
objectivation des capacités humaines une
objectivation dans les algorithmes et la
base du du projet politique du numérique
c'est cela il faut essayer de le
comprendre d'y résister comme on peut
tout en sachant que c'est le numérique
est aussi très utile et que nous avons
besoin de lui jean bernard schmid plus
sur la question du démantèlement
possible bon on peut espérer on peut
rêver il pourrait y avoir une réaction
effectivement international cette
question qui amène à ça à cette question
donc elle se pose quand même fortement
aux etats unis
moi certes ça sera difficile on peut
avoir un petit optimisme quand même par
rapport à ça c'est à dire que si on y
arriver par exemple on pourrait imaginer
que l'on crée cependant je dis ça c'est
pas moi qui les ai imaginé un seuil à
l'autre il ya des gens qui ont imaginé
ça je m'en créé par exemple vraiment à
facebook france facebook a trop tard ça
non bah moi je suis pas si sûr parce que
dans nos usages et non mais justement
les nouvelles règles de whatsapp j'ai
essayé de convaincre mes amis de quitter
mais finalement ça pour passer sur
d'autres un fils de conversations
ralentisse mais oui mais ça a été de la
croix et la bannière moralité on est
tous revenus droite ça mais je perçois
de créer
je me suis maintenant de la place qua
non c'est pas ça c'est si on démantèle
la société s'appuie sur it a réalisé
exactement au point facebook a créé une
société en france quelques invités en
allemagne où se situe en grande-bretagne
servent certes ce sera toujours facebook
mais ça sera pas la même chose parce que
à ce moment là parce que vous l'avez
très bien dit tout à l'heure facebook
aujourd'hui c'est la loi américaine
c'est d'ailleurs le modèle du free
speech américain c'est pas pour rien
qu'on dit tout et n'importe quoi sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est parce que cet
emprunt de cette tradition d'expression
totale américaine qui fait qu'on a cette
île du zouk on peut tout dire sur les
réseaux sociaux et s'il ya des dérapages
c'est pas à cause du choix du
pseudonymat qui est plus la réalité que
l'anonymat c'est pas simplement à coussa
seco vous avez cette idée à partir du
moment où vous arrivez sur twitter etc
ou sur tous les autres mais c'est la
charge totale vous pouvez tout dire je
vous parle pas des effets de meute donc
si on disait pardon je termine juste il
ya peut-être un petit espoir quand même
rare que je suis optimiste là dessus
mais il ya peut-être un petit espoir on
le fait que à partir du moment où s'y
est vraiment une société en france par
exemple ou en allemagne je dis ça parce
que c'est des pays acp c'est qu'ils sont
aussi assez sévère là dessus et qu'on
dit déjà maintenant vous êtes un éditeur
à messia un vrai statut d'éditeur ça
sera plus la même chose là ils seront
responsables des
sur les médias c'est qu'il ya aussi
cette idée que justement mais la règle
d'expression change parce qu'on nous
n'avons pas la même tradition en france
et cette règle pourrait changer qu'il
pourrait y avoir une évolution après sur
le reste et sur la masse et sur les
habitudes phénoménal que ça engendre et
là effectivement il y aura du mal on
aura du mal à changer les choses on peut
aussi réguler jean mathieu est toujours
avec nous 2 / / depuis depuis sa cabine
à on voit ces scènes c'est de là que
vous travaillez sur sur tweets avec
votre votre chaîne sur ce réseau social
est ce que vous faites de la pédagogie
aussi sur surtout ce qu'on vient de dire
voyez sur sur le fait que ce soit pas un
déversoir et que et que on a une
responsabilité de citoyen quand on
intervient sur les réseaux sociaux mais
bien sûr absolument et vous voyez
d'ailleurs l'actualité rattrape ce qu'on
est en train de se dire sur ce plateau
c'est à dire que à l'occasion du
discours sur l'état de l'union la
présidente de la commission européenne a
rappelé que la régulation des gars femme
allait arriver à l'agenda européen au
cours au cours des trimestres qui
viennent la présidence française de
l'union européenne sera aussi l'occasion
pour emmanuel macron d'avancé dans le
sens justement de la régulation des
réseaux sociaux pour défendre ce que
disait jean bernard schmid c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'il ya une manière
européenne de faire les choses d'une
manière américaine sert on la connaît la
question la liberté d'expression et
l'ail est une bonne est un bon exemple
qui est une manière américaine de penser
la liberté d'expression mais aussi une
manière européenne et nos amis
américains et nous n'avons pas le même
passé n'avons pas le même rapport à des
comportements comme par exemple
antisémitisme comme par exemple le
sexisme et donc je suis moi aussi le
premier à réclamer que notre manière à
nous en europe de penser le droit se
retrouve aussi dans dans voilà dans
votre manière de contrôler les réseaux
sociaux il se trouve que il se trouve
que les internautes sont prêts à
comprendre ça regardez le verger pdc un
très bon exemple avec a donné jean
bernard schmidt tout à l'heure les gars
femmes s'y sont ni pour une simple et
bonne raison c'est parce que l'europe
l'a imposée à partir en hausse à dire
obligatoire dès le lendemain matin les
dégâts femmes mettent en place les
choses c'est pas si c'est pas des gens
hors la loi c'est des choix qui ce qui
se contraignent à la loi encore faut-il
que la loi interviennent donc le
politique n'est pas démuni face aux gars
femmes c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai du
tout il ya des choses à faire et des
choses sur lesquelles on peut progresser
et il se trouve qu'un paquet
personnalités politiques qui souhaitent
avancer dans ce sens là donc on est en
train on est à l'onu prise un petit peu
du politique sur les géants du numérique
il ya des batailles qui vont devoir être
mené et on va y arriver mais les
internautes sont prêts à le faire moi je
m'en j'en suis convaincu ça vous fait
rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être dit
en prenant l'horizontalité dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure qui est
d'ailleurs en contradiction avec la
verticalité de la règle économique et du
capitalisme ou un strict tiens puisque
ce sont des tout à fait traditionnelle
ce côté là qui guide les réseaux sociaux
on a quand même on voit quand même une
expression
populaire
contredire celle du tiers état qui se
cherche depuis des siècles
kim
qui n'a pas des coups dans les dans
l'idéologie dominante et les sphères
officielles de la société qu'on l'a vu
dans la mobilisation des jets les gens
dire le bon côté des légendes
celui de la fin de la sphère et les
réseaux sociaux en ont permis cela c'est
à dire une prise de parole à côté de la
prise de parole de même les personnes
que nous sommes de ces bons voilà
il ya eu il faut se souvenir des états
généraux de 1789 le roi les convoque
pour une certaine parole populaire
s'exprime tout en l'encadrant et ça ça
explose ça explose complètement je crois
que les réseaux sociaux
qu'on a vu avec les gilet jaune et par
rapport à quoi le prisa macron c'est
très mal débrouillé alors que c'était
une très grande chance pour lui le grand
débat mais le grand débat c'est
finalement été pour lui une façon de de
briller facilement et de de retourner
affaire en évidence que devant des
années lumière la parole d'eads et gilet
jaune je crois que les réseaux sociaux
peuvent être cette parole qui se cherche
qui est celle du tiers état et que nous
parce que nous sommes des gens diplômés
du kit nous ne pouvons nous ne pouvons
même pas la concevoir alors je reviens
sur un tout dernier thème sûr puisqu'on
parle du démantèlement parler des outils
de nos états final pour résister à ces
nouveaux léviathan est ce que l'arm
fiscale peut être utilisée coûté le
milieu de l'économie 5 juin on est au g7
finances il se réjouit de la création
d'un impôt mondial minimes hommes bruno
le maire c'est un accord historique
après quatre ans de combat la france a
eu gain de cause il y aura bien une
taxation des gens du digital il y aura
bien une taxation minimale à l'impôt ces
sociétés pour éviter l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale qui révoltent pas
juste le titre à nos compatriotes et
alors il le fait ou évidemment il le
poste gauche sur ferrer
sur twitter la smala est ce que c'est un
levier ça est ce que vous y croyez
levier fiscal on va conclure là dessus
alors le levier fiscal oui enfin il
fallait abandonner arriver à une
harmonisation fiscale pour éviter en
fait le dumping fiscal absolument légale
donc retrouvé en faites les sécher
sociaux dégâts femmes en particulier en
irlande donc avec des avec des taux
beaucoup plus attractifs pour ne pas
tellement pour la question de la
régulation directe des réseaux sociaux
mais plus pour des questions de contrôle
plus général de la de
des gars femmes et pour des histoires
plus de souveraineté numérique en
réalité puisque l'un des grands sujets
c'est que l'europe étant
particulièrement en retard
technologiquement
on se retrouve complètement dépendant
des techno et des plateformes
américaines le problème étant que y
compris en territorialise on avait aussi
un sujet d'extraterritorialité du droit
c'est à dire on avait des coûts des lois
comme le cloud qui permet en fait de
rapatrier un paquet de données donc le
fait d harmoniser wii permet peut-être
de trouver plus de coordination
dans la gouvernance merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
robert decker votre livre réseaux
sociaux la guerre des léviathan est donc
publié aux éditions du rocher voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission demain
édition spéciale de
bonjour chez vous rien d'en signer
reçoit l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe ce sera à 8h20 voilà horaires
horaires original horaires spéciale
également pour l'ancien premier ministre
je vous dis aussi à demain salut